[Música]
rechazo internacional generalizado tras
el golpe estaba en mi armar el ejército
tomó el control del gobierno del país
asiático declaró el estado de emergencia
por un año la líder del partido
gobernante y no el de paz sansón succi
fue detenida este lunes la unión la onu
washington china reino unido y la unión
europea condenaron el golpe
y los autores del golpe estaba en
mianmar justifican su accionar
argumentando que hubo fraude en las
elecciones de noviembre en las que el
partido a la cabeza han shan su chip
ganó por una abrumadora mayoría les
contaremos cómo se llegó hasta este
punto
bayón tec y fisher prometieron este
lunes hasta 75 millones de vacunas
adicionales para la unión europea en el
segundo trimestre del año 2021
tras optimizar sus procesos de
producción el anuncio de pantex se
produce antes de una cumbre de
vacunación convocada por el gobierno
alemán con representantes de las
farmacéuticas y de la unión europea
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 soy re blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo con el golpe de estado en
mianmar y el rechazo internacional que
ha generado el ejército tomó el poder en
el país asiático y anunció el estado de
emergencia por un año luego que
detuvieran aún san suu kyi la líder del
partido gobernante ya todo su gabinete
las tensiones se incrementaron entre el
ejecutivo y la cúpula militar tras las
elecciones de noviembre que los
militares consideran manipuladas veamos
el siguiente informe
tras meses de tensiones latentes el
ejército de mianmar ha llevado a cabo lo
que muchos temían un golpe de
estado-militar en un mensaje transmitido
a través de un canal de televisión que
pertenece a los militares se anunció que
el ejército tomaba el control del país
durante un año con el fin de llevar a
cabo el escrutinio de las listas de
votantes y tomar medidas
la autoridad de la legislación la
gobernanza y la jurisdicción de la
nación se transfiere al comandante en
jefe en conformidad con el artículo 418
su artículo a tampa bay sigue luchando
yo también perdí el partido gobernante
de mianmar aseguró que aún son sus y fue
arrestada en una redada matutina junto
con otras figuras importantes del
oficialismo un movimiento significativo
que se produce el día que se suponía que
el parlamento se reuniría por primera
vez desde las elecciones de noviembre
desde esa votación las tensiones han
aumentado entre los líderes civiles del
país y sus poderosos militares los
líderes del ejército afirman que las
elecciones que aún sanssouci ganó de
forma aplastante fueron fraudulentas los
informes de los medios dicen que se
cortaron las líneas telefónicas en
internet
la capital y la televisión estatal no
pudo transmitir también ha habido
informes de soldados en las calles de
las grandes ciudades las condenas en
todo el mundo por lo ocurrido no han
tardado washington amenazó con una
respuesta si los líderes civiles no son
liberados aún sanssouci ha dirigido
mianmar durante los últimos cinco años
en el pasado fue vista como un icono de
la paz en occidente pero su liderazgo se
ha visto empañado por el trato brutal a
la minoría musulmana rohingya del país
considerada por naciones unidas como un
pueblo sin estado
y es que hoy 1º de febrero me han mar
tenía que vivir la juramentación de los
parlamentarios y políticos escogidos en
las elecciones del 8 de noviembre sin
embargo el país amaneció este lunes hora
local con este golpe de estado la
posición cercana a los castrenses
denunciado irregularidades que tanto la
comisión electoral como la comunidad
internacional lo niegan luís muñoz nos
muestra como el país llegó hasta esta
crisis actual de gobierno
es min online jefe del ejército de
mianmar el 27 de enero había dicho a
soldados del ejército que la
constitución debía abolir se si no se
cumplía un día antes uno de sus
portavoces se había negado a descartar
un golpe de estado desde las elecciones
de noviembre el partido de la
solidaridad y el desarrollo de la unión
creado por la junta militar que gobernó
entre 1962 y 2011 está denunciando
fraude en la victoria del partido liga
nacional para la democracia de la premio
nobel de la paz aún san suu si la
comisión electoral negó cualquier fraude
así como la comunidad internacional
desde eeuu hasta la unión europea el
partido liberal de succi consiguió el
83% de los escaños es decir 396 de los
476 de ambas cámaras del parlamento
aumentando el apoyo desde que el 2015
llegase al poder
succi que no puede ser presidenta por
tener familiares de otras nacionalidades
esa líder de su partido y el presidente
responde ante ella cabe destacar que
estuvo bajo arresto domiciliario hasta
pese a que su fama cayó por la limpieza
étnica de la minoría musulmana rohingya
sigue contando con respaldo de la
ciudadanía de mianmar sin embargo los
militares controlan un país que no ha
terminado de democratizarse y que vive
una guerra constante desde 1948 con
múltiples guerrillas en las periferias
el 25 por ciento de los escaños
parlamentarios pertenecen al cuerpo
militar además de ocupar tres
ministerios interior que controlan los
servicios públicos defensa y fronteras
por lo que el ejército nunca se ha
sometido a un gobierno civil tampoco se
ha conseguido una verdadera
federalización de un país de mayoría
budista que cuenta con 135 etnias ni
tampoco se ha logrado una efectiva
separación de poderes
y tras estos hechos ocurridos en mi amar
eeuu se opuso a lo que considera un
intento para alterar el resultado de las
recientes elecciones y tomar acciones
contra los responsables si estas medidas
no se revierten por su parte el
secretario general de la organización de
naciones unidas antonio guterres condenó
firmemente el arresto por el ejército de
danzas huchín y de otros dirigentes
políticos mientras que la unión europea
y el gobierno chino también se sumaron
al rechazo internacional tras este golpe
de estado
tienes un vecino amistoso de mianmar y
espera que las distintas partes en el
país resuelvan adecuadamente sus
diferencias bajo el marco constitucional
y legal para proteger la estabilidad
política y social event y vamos hasta
bruselas con nuestra corresponsal
esther herrera esther muy buen día cuál
es la posición oficial de la unión
europea
luego de este golpe de estado ocurrió en
mianmar
buenos días pues estupor e indignación
en la unión europea tras este atentado
en mi andar todos los presidentes de las
en situaciones europeas han condenado de
forma enérgica este nuevo movimiento del
ejército el presidente del consejo
europeo charles michel y también el jefe
de la diplomacia europea de murray han
pedido la liberación inmediata de todos
los detenidos entre ellos la nobel de la
paz aung san suu live y recuerdan que
debe respetarse el camino a la
democracia iniciado en el país en 2011
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen ha asegurado que el
gobierno del país debe volver a volver a
sus funciones de acuerdo con la
constitución del país y las elecciones
del pasado noviembre además el
presidente el parlamento europeo david
se ha sol y ha asegurado que toda la
institución está unida así como todos
los países europeos en una condena al
golpe perpetrado en mianmar aún así
precisamente el parlamento europeo y
retiró el galardón del premio sajarov
aún san suu kyi
y el genocidio según la onu de la
minoría de los rohingyas hace tres años
estas gracias por la información y es
que luego de todo este terremoto
político en mianmar varios de sus
ciudadanos alrededor del mundo salieron
a las calles a protestar en rechazo a lo
ocurrido
cientos de manifestantes pertenecientes
a la comunidad de mianmar en japón se
reunieron en tokio la capital del país
para protestar contra la detención de
los líderes del país y pidieron a la onu
que condenara aún más estas acciones del
ejército en tailandia los birmanos
afirmaron una protesta en bangkok que
estaban conmocionados y entristecidos
por este golpe de estado
y cambiamos ahora de información y
volvemos hasta la unión europea porque
la empresa alemana bayón tech anunció
que suministrará el bloque comunitario
75 millones de dosis de su vacuna en su
en el segundo trimestre 2021 tras
optimizar sus procesos de producción en
la jefa de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen se pronunció al respecto
veamos
estamos trabajando con empresas
farmacéuticas para garantizar que las
vacunas se entreguen a los europeos
variante que facer administrar a 75
millones de dosis adicionales en el
segundo trimestre del año y hasta 600
millones en total en 2021 vamos hasta
rusia donde ayer domingo 31 de enero los
agentes desplegados para contener las
movilizaciones convocadas en varias
ciudades del país en respaldo al líder
opositor
alexei naval y detuvieron a más de 5.000
manifestantes
las protestas en apoyan a bali quien
permanece detenido tras haber retornado
al país luego de haber sido envenenado
en agosto 2020 se realizaron bajo el
lema rusia libre uno de los reclamos de
los partidarios de naval y fue el de la
libertad para los que consideran presos
políticos así como la salida del poder
del presidente vladimir
aquí está entonces el panorama
internacional esta mañana del lunes
continue con nosotros para más
información buen día
[Música]
bienvenidos a la crónica de historia de
france 24 como todas las semanas abrimos
para ustedes las puertas del pasado en
un viaje por la historia para ayudar